okay so we're it Tommy and Lucy where
y'all at so okay what about you what's
the worst gift ever
so we've been married for 11 years now
our first there our first year of
marriage she got me something very very
inspiring and nice and thoughtful and
I'm scared she she bought me skydiving
or the day and that was welcomed deathly
afraid of all of it so it actually ended
up being the worst day of my life wait
so wait are you terrified of Scott are
you terrified of that like I would never
do that yeah no totally like why jump
out of a perfectly good airplane totally
scared of heights so it was the worst
thing she could have gotten but but once
she got it I was like all right now I
have to prove this now now I have to do
this because I can't let her have
bragging rights for the rest of our
lives so I was like I'm gonna get on
that shame I would have backed out Betty
on that plan you know so Lucy wait did
you know that he was afraid of heights
or was that a surprise well we were
about a year into our marriage
so I mean naturally he played kind of
tough and manly didn't really show his
fears that I knew he didn't like roller
coasters but I didn't know the full
height extense
and my thought was ever since I was a
high in high school I've always wanted
to go skydiving like bucket list I want
to do this before I have kids jump out
of a perfectly good airplane Oh what
better gift than to give my new husband
possible dad I thought we were we we
were now united as one why not give him
one of my dream come true by jumping out
of it
I like how do you work here I'm gonna
start working my gifts in like that for
my husband you would love this it's
really for me that is amazing you
survived it though right
yeah I mean I mean it was a little scary
for those of you that may have done it
when you're on the edge of the airplane
there's someone that forces you out
there's someone on your back right and
they push you at night my instinct was
that supports backwards to stay in the
plane but then you can see there he
throws me out of the plane and I would
be throwing fists I would be that would
know that ain't my thing Hey I'm so
happy y'all enjoyed it I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this